[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
i got my cell phone as a hot spot and
tommy's sitting there doing online
school
oh 2020 is a weird year man
we're gonna lose our sunlight in about
one to two hours and it's supposed to be
a low of 27 degrees tonight
it's gonna get cold so i'm gonna bust my
sleeping bag out
and kind of use it as a template to see
the dimensions that we need for our
shelter
[Music]
all the lumps gone okay
hey
is
here one no
we're getting tommy changed and ready
for bed before it gets too cold
and i've got these adhesive body warmers
and these things are awesome just take
the sticker off there
put one there so you wake up
when it comes to cold weather bags
there's not many good kid-sized bags
um big agnes makes the little red series
there's three different sizes and this
is the middle one
it's really good it's a 15 degree bag
and it's got this sleeve on it
so that you can insert the kids mat
and they don't roll off their mat
all right i'm going to start a fire with
my blast match it's a ferrous rod
on a spring with a little bit of steel
here you go and stab it like that it
makes
big sparks but the advantage of this is
you can do it one-handed so one hand's
holding the tinder
and the other's making the sparks
okay sticks hold on yeah
time to eat and for dinner i got a
couple things i've got some cheese and
crackers with fruit and fig
marmalade and we've got two beautiful
steaks and roasted marshmallows for
dessert
feels so late doesn't it i think it's
only like six o'clock
a chunk of gouda with a pear some fig
marmalade on a cracker
that's good
let's just stick this right here
[Music]
it's time to roast marshmallows those
are big
these are the hugest marshmallow there
there you go buddy
what's the food with the uh yeah i've
got all me
wait as much as you can off your fingers
and i'll let you use my hanky
well our bellies are full of good food
and this fire is nice and warm and it's
a good thing too
because it is cold out here you can
really
feel the cold creeping in but uh this
shelter's actually doing
a pretty good job there's an icy breeze
out here but it's only six o'clock so me
and tom i'm gonna hang out and tell
stories before we go to bed and uh
just having a great time
how's that that warmer
just right over here let me
get lost in there last night okay
all right we're gonna put you like your
donut buddy
yeah i'm gonna warm mine up they're kind
of frozen
this is good yeah
hard-boiled eggs are one of those foods
that grossed me out so much as a kid
and i absolutely love them now
especially
when they're warm and it's cold like
this oh they're so good
i think it's time to make tommy a chair
for online school
all right
good that's it cozy
so this is why i drew any but so which
one
it's getting colder and colder and we
even have a small chance of a snowstorm
this afternoon
so i want to upgrade our shelter really
all we have is a tarp over us i want
something that's going to block the wind
and retain the heat from that fire a
little bit better so we're going to cut
some more wood
[Music]
ain't late
um
[Music]
so
food
[Music]
oh
right
it's gonna get dark soon tom why don't
you go and find some firewood and pile
up some firewood over there
oh it's good having him get old and be
helpful
[Music]
see those coals
[Music]
i want my apple brown i'm gonna make you
some
pan bread tom
just a bag of all-purpose flour with a
pinch of yeast and sugar
well we mix up the dough just to set
this aside let the yeast do its thing
for
about an hour
[Music]
sitting here in the chair chilling
peanuts by the fire
pretty nice man it's starting to get
cold though i got this fire up
oh
these walls really help i can feel the
heat coming from this side of me as well
and actually never stopped it dad
[Music]
right though oh
it's a it's a bit colder than it was
last night
oh
you put it on after you click it
what was that dear gun
that was a gun that's loud
oh whatever you like that
i'm gonna keep working on the walls i've
got a lot of cutting to do yet
so
back up
we got spears we got a hunt bear with
those
uh
tommy are you hungry i think some steak
sandwiches sound
real good right now
nothing fancy just seasoned cooked
shaved steak provolone cheese and
some ciabattas
back to work
[Applause]
i'm thomas
what's up
[Music]
um
that nice tommy
oh my oh that looks good
oh that looks roaring right that heat
just gets
it just gets kicked right back from the
from the wood you're perfect
look at that yeah we were able to bring
a lot of fresh food on this trip because
it was so cold when we started out but
it's gotten warm so we need to eat all
of our meat right away
is that good um
it has been a long day all right guys
we'll see you in the morning
well today it's a little bit windier and
a little bit cooler
and it rained pretty good last night you
can see
right there yeah we got a lot of water
in there but we're done with breakfast
so
we're gonna tear the tent down and keep
working on building this thing
we got the log wall up as high as i dare
make it and i learned a couple things
the taller the wall
and the longer the wall is the more
important it is
that the logs be symmetrical and
straight as an arrow and
if you do have a log that's a little bit
off
it should be near the top not the bottom
so because of that i ended up having to
start over after i was about four or
five logs deep on this
wall and i just realized man these these
logs aren't cutting it
and i cut them up and used them for this
shorter wall instead
and they seem to be working just fine
over here on this shorter wall
now i just need to put a couple more
rows on this wall i need to shore this
thing up a little bit better so it's
more sturdy
and then we're going to get started on
this wall
[Music]
i gotta tell you i got a lot of sawing
to do and i'm really getting tired and
kneeling down on the ground to do it i
think i need to build something to fix
that
that wait
[Music]
stop and i found him oh look at that
that is cool i've never seen one that
color before
oh do we have any empty container
here's an empty water bottle right
behind your green backpack
look i just found that one and that one
and that one they're
pretty i bet they're poisonous me too
so don't eat them
you just found two more yeah see we got
what six newts already
more than six actually i think you're a
nuke catching machine
well we've eaten up most of our fancy
food so we're gonna have a little bit of
more
simple dinner we've got some canned stew
and
some little potatoes we're gonna put in
the coals
for dessert we're eating leftover
halloween candy tax
well it's already pretty chilly so me
and tommy are hopping in our sleeping
bags and uh we're gonna
stay up and watch documentaries on our
phone about salamanders
oh
today's another school day so tommy's
gonna do some more online school
catch
make it appropriate okay
how's it coming tell me
come back
that looks absolutely amazing but i'm
hungry
and school starts again soon so we
better get some lunch made oh no
this cedar bark's pretty awesome stuff i
thought cedar bark too
yeah that's gonna that's gonna go up
quick
there we go i didn't even have to blow
on that look at that
oh that smells good too i must be really
hungry because
this is really doing it for me this is
one of those days where it tastes so
[Music]
good
[Music]
tommy's doing his online p.e
[Music]
[Applause]
tell mother i love her
september
he's playing the turkey ninja game for
his pe homework
i found this feather oh that looks like
a turkey feather man yeah yeah yeah i
think so too i think we should hunt and
cook up a turkey if we can oh
huh
there we go we've got a platform to
sleep on so when it rains and
bottom of this thing fills with mud
we'll be okay
well we've been at this for five days
and supplies are running a bit low
my gopro batteries are almost all dead
we could use some fresh food we're out
of marshmallows
and we all badly need a shower but uh
it's
thanksgiving here in two days so we're
gonna go home
uh hang out with the family resupply and
at the end of the week we're gonna come
back
and finish this project let's do it
right
look at the shelter here oh
look at this we have a bathtub tommy
look at how deep that is this is
stretching the heck out of our rope too
i think if it hadn't been resting on the
bread it would have just ripped our
tarp off watch out this is gonna this is
gonna make a flood
oh look at that that is pretty
watertight and there's barely any water
coming out there
all right i think we've got a fair
amount of work to do
i'm going to sort it out a little bit
[Music]
i thought about lashing these to the
wood the same way i did this chair
but it took so much paracord to do this
lashing
so it just seemed a lot more reasonable
to bring some recycled
nails than to go and buy a thousand feet
of paracord
well this is much more level than what
we were sleeping on before which means
we'll stay on our pads better and won't
end up in a big dog pile at the end of
the night
got the bed nailed down now i need to
take care of the back wall and for that
i'm gonna need
a lot of logs
well i got 11 trees chopped down but the
sun is starting to set on me so i think
i better get a fire started and get our
tent up because
it's supposed to get into the 20s
tonight
tom what'd you find oh another another
salamander what's in his hand
little froglet is that nice tommy
for dinner tonight we have a very
special tinfoil dinner here
and i just need to get it warmed up so
we're gonna just sit
here by the fire let it heat up
okay
well thanksgiving was just a couple days
ago so i've got some leftover turkey
mashed potatoes gravy
yams and uh homemade cranberry sauce you
like that tom
yeah oh yeah mine was turkey and that
mess
together it was good oh yeah all right
tommy you want to watch a movie
all right let's watch a movie
oh good morning it's a little bit below
freezing
we uh we stayed pretty warm last night
just sitting here eating some cherry
strudel and
i'm gonna get a fire started we need to
warm this place up
really so cold that when i touch it
feels like my
all right today's the day we're gonna
get that back wall up let's do it
um
hard to beat a hot dog on a campfire
hey tom what do you think
[Music]
all right
it's wow really
i just broke the tip off my knife i've
had this thing for 17 years it was a
gift from a friend in japan
i could fix it though
i have seven birds in a tree so i'm
going to circle
those with green so here are five
six and seven not subtract
so it's not this one because we are not
adding
we have
man sun's getting low and i really want
to finish this roof but i gotta get
dinner cooking
there we go
like don't do it okay here it is
well that's going to take a long time to
cook so while that's roasting
go ahead and work on the ceiling
well we are not done but this is as far
as we're gonna get today cutting
firewood
is a constant thing
look at that roast this thing looks
gorgeous tommy's been in charge of
cooking this thing yep i have been
stoking the fire putting my own
firewood in it you've been turning it
too
yep you like first dips
so good dad got your got your plate
oh god it's so good that's so good yeah
this is yours
yeah that's all right nothing on that
but can't fire smoke and salt buddy or
natural
that is good
okay
oh thermometer says it's 33 degrees
outside it's supposed to get down to 21
tonight but this fire
is roaring and it is so warm and nice in
here it's just cozy
meantime we're gonna hop in our bags
here and we're gonna watch a movie and
i'm gonna see you guys in the morning
i have got to get some firewood and get
that fire started
does that feel good to have that inside
me and tommy have been sitting here
talking and we think we need to name
our little cabin here i think we should
call it jabba
the hutt ah bad joke
i'm surprised this saw has done as well
as it has but it is super dull
and it's developed quite a bit of play
in it so it may not last
much longer
well trimmed up the walls and posts now
i'm going to stake down the tarp real
good
she's looking pretty good let me give
you the tour
what do you think tommy is this cozy
but still i think there's a few
improvements i'd like to make i think
there needs to be some sort of roof
structure here so if the wind's blowing
the rain really aggressively this
direction
we don't get wet additionally i really
need to do something with our latrine
situation i'd like to build a proper
little outhouse
and i think we need to put chinking in
between the logs
um get some sort of mud or moss or grass
and shove it in between the logs
well tommy should we go home and see
mama yep all right guys
well don't forget to click subscribe to
the outdoor boys youtube channel and
check out our camping and adventure
playlist
and our fun project playlist we have
dozens of videos from camping all over
the world
and some pretty awesome project videos
including our floating fishing cabin
video
and our two man camper hand cart video
but thanks for watching
and don't forget to click subscribe we
put out new videos every saturday
morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching